las federaciones y sindicatos de
profesionales del sector salud inician
la huelga nacional indefinida se exige
aumento del presupuesto del 6% del
producto bruto interno mejores
condiciones laborales y salariales así
como el pago de bonos por atender la
pandemia del cómic 19 todos los
profesionales de la salud nos sentimos
burlados hemos sido engañados no nos ha
cumplido con las actas de acuerdo no nos
dan los equipos de protección adecuados
no hay pruebas moleculares no hay
pruebas de antígeno nos falta oxígeno
nos falta cámara de ventiladores los
profesionales sanitarios también exigen
la renuncia de la ministra de salud
pilar mazzetti a quien responsabilizan
por en lo que ellos denominan un mal
manejo de la atención de la pandemia el
coronavirus así como el retraso en la
compra de las vacunas no ha cumplido con
la clase trabajadora también ha cumplido
con la población
al tema de las vacunas es importante
precisar que todos estamos unidos acá
todos los profesionales de la salud
exigiendo la inmediata destitución de la
ministra pilar mazzetti por cuanto su
trabajo en el portafolio deja mucho que
desear la huelga médica se produce
cuando pero afronta una segunda ola del
joven 19 y el colapso de los hospitales
ante la falta de camas en las unidades
de cuidados intensivos una situación
crítica para el gobierno del presidente
francisco sagasti